yo what's up guys before we get into
this episode we just want to make a
quick announcement today february 8th is
our one year anniversary all right our
first episode the origins of viola
episode premiered exactly a year ago
today and who would have thought 365
days later we'd be saying this episode
is brought to you by miller lite
let's go
so right now i know this sounds insane
but right now you can go to your
computer or your phone type in
millerlite.com
slash yola it's going to bring up a
landing page of every place around you
that delivers miller lite or you can go
to any single place on earth that sells
beer and grab yourself a 12 pack right
now this is miller lite for every can
there's 96 only 96 calories 3.2 grams of
carbs so let us know in the comments
guys what does miller lite mean to you
to me like i said it's camaraderie it's
hanging out with my uncle it's bonfires
it just reminds me of all the fun times
before the episode starts guys we just
want to say a huge shout out to miller
lite thank you for making this the 2022
brand ambassadors guys this is the one
year anniversary did not think we'd be
doing this ad read one year in thank you
guys so much for making it possible
let's start the episode
uh celebrate me miller brewing company
uh milwaukee wisconsin
[Music]
yo what's up everybody i am thomas
dobaziola whatever you want to call me
welcome back to the dope as usual
podcast we're here to talk about life
drugs problems accomplishments and
everything in between i am here with
marty o'neal the [ __ ] is up what's going
on d monetized right off the bat
it's all good uh guys today we are here
with
someone that you've asked for
non-fucking stop i'm just gonna start
cussing and we're done um adam 22 thank
you for being here
like the golf club
how you doing man i'm good man thank you
for being here yeah i've been seeing in
the comments uh quite a bit so i'm happy
to be here well thank you for coming man
um
first i want to ask you a question
because i
i mean i've been watching no jumper for
2017 maybe 16 okay right
nobody ever
it asks you some [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying it's always the other way around
so where are you from i have no idea i
am from a place called nashua new
hampshire also known as hash brown town
why
uh well my boy a.d who i do the podcast
with he's from compton
he created that nickname because i think
it's kind of hard for him to wrap his
head around what new hampshire is so he
calls it hashbrown town bro that is such
a small obscure ass state yeah how
[ __ ] shitty was that nobody knows
anything about it uh nothing you know
it's just like a kind of like suburban
small city upbringing you know it's
about 40 minutes outside of boston so
it's like i kind of always had like the
city that i was very much drawn to as a
young kid you know going to the aquarium
as a little kid and then growing up all
of a sudden i'm 12 13 i'm like getting
my parents to drive me to the train
station so i could go ride bmx bikes in
boston and [ __ ] like that but you know
this is like a nice little downtown type
area in nashua but really there's like
probably like a hundred different little
cities outside of like boston in that
general
45 minute drive type region like a lot
of the people who live in nashua new
hampshire drive into boston to work so
it was kind of a very humble normal
american upbringing
it sounds cool but boring as [ __ ] to be
out there just as a kid you had to you
had to go for it if you wanted to make
something happen for sure yeah you built
well so you're doing uh bmx's are you in
the forest i'm imagining some goonies
style no i mean it's like a small city
so it's like you know we had like a
pretty decent skate park by the time
that i was like 15 or whatever and like
i mean there was all kinds of like rails
and stairs and colleges it should like
it's not like it is a small ass place
compared to you know l.a or what we're
used to but it wasn't like
that rural it's not like i lived on a
farm but like if i were to drive
20 minutes in most directions from where
i was growing up you would be more or
less at a farm so same place i grew up
as a city surrounded by agriculture
right same [ __ ] so as a kid in a boring
ass place like that like just like me
bmx and were you a good kid until you
hit a certain age were you always
[ __ ] doing something wild always bad
i was in trouble i was always just like
i got arrested multiple times for like
shoplifting and graffiti and and in the
small town fighting like all kinds of
[ __ ] yeah i was like really like the
worst kid that like [ __ ] in school at
a certain point for sure i would say i
was probably like the
worst behaved kid
most ridiculous non-diagnosed add just
while in the [ __ ] out like i was i was
really really bad kid i mean to put in
perspective because it's like it's a
small town but like our high school was
like 2 000 kids oh you grew up in town
like mine yeah it's decent size you know
yeah some [ __ ] going on so you were a
bad kid i was are you an only child no i
had a younger sister three years younger
than me oh okay so what are your parents
doing are they [ __ ] pissed uh at that
time yes they were pretty deeply upset
my parents were like very much like
like when they talk about their
childhoods they grew up like really poor
me and my sister grew up with like you
know a little bit of money in the bank
for our college funds and [ __ ] like that
my parents had
they very much believed that if they
worked hard and kept their nose down and
grinded that they would be able to make
a better life for their kids and stuff
my sister
good kid like went to did well in high
school went on did well in college got a
good job started a family et cetera with
me it was like i was just really
attracted to graffiti bmx
bad [ __ ] basically i was like getting in
trouble like from like all the time from
a young age i got into credit card fraud
when i was like 19. jesus yeah i was i
was pretty much just doing whatever man
so did you go to college i went to yeah
i did a year at middlesex community
college which is just like a local small
college like in massachusetts and then i
went to
school where you actually stay at the
school for a year at a umass lowell
after that and then i
started making some decent money doing
credit card fraud dipped out moved to
new york city and uh [ __ ] really started
cracking from there more or less
what in terms of what well
cracking cards and and doing other stuff
because i moved out there because i
basically had made like 100 grand doing
credit cards
at 19 and then i was just like you know
what [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm moving to new
york i want to be a bmx filmer i kind of
decided that like this is not good for
my mental health
to be doing all these purchases under
other people's identities and [ __ ] like
i had a homie who got caught and it just
you know i was scared like
he's a pretty with the prison i'm
assuming nah he really just had to pay
like restitution because this was like
2004 so like when they would catch you
for doing credit card fraud they didn't
really know what the [ __ ] you were doing
like they i remember when they charged
him the restitution for his [ __ ] it was
like not even close to the amount of
work that he had been putting in that
day even on that card so at that time
they were so not equipped to prosecute
people for this [ __ ]
[ __ ] so you moved to la and you're i
mean i moved to new york and you're
doing b you want to be a bmx filmer so
obviously you're still riding bmx heavy
i was just going out every day riding
bikes hanging out because it was like
the golden age of bmx in new york city
like 2003.
uh you could go to union square which is
like this park right in the middle of
manhattan and it was like all the
skaters and bmx dudes hanging out there
drinking smoking like all [ __ ] night
and like the pros like the dudes i was
seeing in magazines and [ __ ] would be
kicking it there too so this was like
heaven on earth to me
so then i [ __ ] my back up like pretty
quickly like just riding and and
realistically couldn't ride for a couple
months that's how i was like you know
okay well i gotta figure out something
else i'm excited about that i'm gonna
start trying to put time into so i
started playing online poker which at
the time i was very very fascinated by
and that led me into basically playing
online poker for a living for like three
years after that
and so then
while i'm playing online poker and
making a decent living i also i'm
spending a lot of time looking at all
these different message boards and stuff
there was like a bmx forum i would be
looking at every day and it started to
like the pieces and started to come
together in my head because i was also
looking at these rap blogs like now
right two dough boys whatever and like
i'm seeing the way that they're sort of
archiving
all this hip-hop content and like making
content making posts out of like oh this
is the new cover of double xl we're
gonna post it on this blog and talk
about it you know the comments section
people going back and forth about it and
i realized like right away like 2005 i'm
like oh i could be that for bmx so then
i just started a blog spot started
running this website about bmx started
selling advertising to all the companies
and [ __ ] and pretty soon i quit playing
online poker because i was doing better
just
running this website
so you've been on social media before it
was a thing oh way before that too i was
on aol and the chatrooms when i was 13
and like 97 and [ __ ] asl
for that [ __ ] were you a heavy hip hop
hat this whole time yeah pretty much i
was always into like uh metal and punk
and [ __ ] as well but like but but
hardcore or excuse me rap was definitely
like my primary interest since i was a
little kid like the first time i heard
snoop dogg i just was geeked like this
is the coolest [ __ ] i ever [ __ ] heard
in my life
and so yeah i always was rap was always
kind of like like i said like i started
the bmx website because i was such a big
rap fan that i'm reading there right
every day checking it oh new lil wayne
song boom i'm listening to it new chic
luch song boom i'm listening to it let's
go and it started to like click in my
head like oh like i could be this but
for bmx bikes no [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
tight i wish i had figured out at that
time that like oh no you could have a
voice in hip-hop too you just gotta take
it you just gotta do it you know i
waited like 10 years
that's all right you i mean i i'm dude i
did not expect you to say that you've
been doing this [ __ ] since before
myspace was even a thing doing forums
and blogs that's where everybody there
was the only online community it was
forums and blogs yep so how long did you
run the bmx for the bmx page for
started in 2006 um
moved to
los angeles actually long beach at the
time in 2010
so uh
and then continued to run it at certain
point i started this other brand on some
[ __ ] that we sort of is like the more
clothing type brand and everything like
that we make videos under that brand and
everything and um i'm living in long
beach having a good time
hustling a little bit still the bmx
stuff was never incredible
money-wise you know so i was having to
make some of them uh them peas fly
across the country and stuff you know
how that is yeah and uh you know but
life was all right and then uh at a
certain point
started to get my money together a
little bit more i opened a bike shop in
downtown l.a called on some [ __ ] and um
part of my reason when i did that i was
like you know i want to be able to put
my brand on display but i also want to
be able to use it as you know
headquarters to be able to [ __ ] with all
the people that i see doing dope things
in the culture because around that time
when i've really been living in la
southern california in general because
of long beach for a couple years it was
like i started to realize like
oh i can't just be doing bike [ __ ] i
have to embrace the culture as a whole
like this i started to like actually
realize like oh there's no reason why i
can't be doing rap content as well like
there's just nothing what's stopping me
like i have an opinion i have artists
that i think are tight that nobody's
trying to interview so i just started to
like you know i was doing bmx rider
interviews in the back of my uh my bike
shop i set up a podcast to do that and
then pretty quickly i just started to
tap in with all these up-and-coming
soundcloud rappers and do that kind of
[ __ ] too
so
that's a crazy transition yeah yeah are
you an actor
are you a videographer like you get down
with the camera i
i guess like i i could be a videographer
like i spent a lot of time filming bmx
throughout the years i was never like
the best filmer but i figured out how to
use the camera and but usually honestly
even from the beginning i would always
like hire somebody who was a little bit
more specialized to basically be the
video guy from early on with the bike
stuff and i mean my early no jumper
interviews we we had a mixer set up and
everything so we could record the audio
properly i would literally take my phone
and put it on a [ __ ] bike rack a bike
stand that they would use by day to work
on bikes i would take a bike out of it
and put my phone in the bike stand and
just hit record and like there's
multiple podcasts from back in the day
like the the ugly god podcast the the
video cuts part way through because like
a girl tried to call me and i forgot to
put my [ __ ] on airplane mode
so stuff like that used to happen well
you guys were just starting trying to do
something that was relatively [ __ ]
new yeah it was there wasn't that many
people doing a video podcast in
particular i was listening to combat
jack and joe budden and joe rogan those
were my three influences at the time
really that made me want to do podcasts
do you still listen to that you still
listen to podcasts even though you
podcast so much
yeah sometimes it can get kind of
overwhelming because like my personal
taste in podcasts on average is more
like
news politics philosophy like a little
bit more high-minded stuff but then i
also like to keep tabs on the million
dollars worth of games and
the brilliant idiots and the andrew
schultz's the flaker twos the [ __ ]
all these i love dj vlad's content he's
i watch his [ __ ] every day i mean a lot
of a lot of different [ __ ] i watch these
days
you're the same wave as us i always say
like i feel like podcasting is going
through right now like what hip-hop did
in the late 80s and the 90s like you got
you run dmc like that whole that might
be rogan and his whole team and now you
kind of have like a new class of
podcasts coming in younger people coming
in that have kind of taken heed to what
that first generation did
you i feel like there's a lot of
parallels well i mean at first it was
like nerds basically like when you look
at a me or a vlad or like you know as
even like a combat jack he was a lawyer
you know you're looking at people who
are like fans
who are kind of ahead of the time on the
technology and everything like that yeah
but then like the next generation what i
see right now is like
the [ __ ] official ass fools like the
big use the [ __ ] you know ti was
going crazy with his for a while before
his [ __ ] got kind of weird like joe
budden obviously one of the kings of the
[ __ ] you know you look you see like a
nick cannon getting in there and stuff
it's basically like all the most
influential
people who who really are like the heart
of the culture
have kind of become podcasters largely
so like it does kind of create like a
little bit of a
pressure on me as somebody who's kind of
like an outsider who was just like
really early on on this type of content
to be like okay well when somebody can
choose to go get interviewed by [ __ ]
nori
you know what makes you stand out what
makes your [ __ ] seem like something that
they would want to tap in with you know
true yeah it's because you're like an
expert it's your perspective your
opinion that's valuable to
hopefully but when you're comparing
yourself to a nori it's like well this
[ __ ] had hit records you know
well
also yeah hit records is great that's
great but this is also an interview
style seeing because when i i used to go
and watch no jumper to see what up cause
i knew if you're on you're about to blow
up yeah because there's a a reason that
they saw like no bring them on bring
them on so i used to go on there and see
the new artists what artist is going to
be coming up next yeah it's like an
artist might not make a great a r and a
r is like a talent they know
you know that mine is a different skill
set same thing with being a good
interviewer yeah and a lot of like the
legendary rappers who do podcasts
they're not great interviewers
but they come with a lot of respect to
the situation exactly which is always
kind of the tricky thing you know like i
feel like with hip-hop and interviews
you gotta earn your respects because
it's like why the [ __ ] would young thug
want to sit down with you you know he
better be looking at you like you're
bringing something to the table because
he's if he's gonna not do an interview
with a nori or nobody or whoever the
[ __ ] it is you know it's like you gotta
you gotta fight for your respect you
know hell yeah cause you don't wanna sit
there and have to struggle to pull a
good interview out if they're sitting
there just being a [ __ ] superstar
because man i seen like larry king
interviewing jay-z one time and he's
asking the dumbest ass questions that no
no hip-hop fan would ever interview
jay-z and be like you know
so i heard you don't
they do say this but i heard you don't
write your lyrics down like all the
corny [ __ ] that they would say to a
jay-z or whatever but it's like if
you're larry king
you get to ask the dumbest questions pos
if you're joe rogan you get to sit down
with snoop dogg and say is the east
coast west coast beef still a thing
which he recently did and i was just
like seriously damn i'm like i don't get
the privilege of getting to ask a basic
ass question like that people expect me
to understand what's going on in the
streets you know it'd be [ __ ]
hilarious if you did though
when my early interviews sometimes when
i go back and watch them i'm like oh wow
i really didn't understand the streets
at all so there was so much [ __ ] that i
was trying to figure out about l.a and
how [ __ ] really works and i'll go back
and see an interview and i'll be like oh
damn you mentioned this rapper to this
dude and their hoods want to kill each
other like you should have not you can't
mention him to him but i didn't [ __ ]
know back then so i'm like kind of
oblivious to some of the [ __ ] that's
going on you know
i am oblivious too i'm from uh mercy you
know where fresno is i'm from merced
like the real [ __ ] town right there nice
like my car is blue right i've never
worn a blue shirt till i moved here
because i don't want to get shot up yeah
i don't want to get killed in my own
town so i know like
those things but la is a whole different
machine
there's sub sections of oh wait blue's
okay here but not [ __ ] 30 yards this
way
it's [ __ ] scary and you have to
remember like i'll be interviewing a
[ __ ] and i'll be thinking i'll mention
a blood hood and then think real quick
like i have to do the
math in my head like wait
no they [ __ ] with them like they're cool
with those bloods
they hate all the other bloods but they
cool with those bloods you got to stay
up to date all these powers extra
pressure [ __ ] getting brief like a
[ __ ] movie like don't say blood it's
not like there's two gangs there's
[ __ ] 500 gangs out there yeah yeah so
you gotta nobody expects me to be 100
aware of everything but i got good
people around me that could let me know
you know at least not say something's
going to get you in trouble yeah for
sure for sure that's the biggest part
yeah um real quick uh before we
[ __ ] forget
for the bmx thing were you trying to
pursue that professionally before you
hurt your back was that something you
were all in on i was i always loved the
culture of it but i was never that good
at it you know like i got hurt a lot
like when i was young
doing stupid as [ __ ] before i even got
to the point of like i've known people
throughout the years who were bold as
[ __ ] would try anything
i never even really got to that point
because i'd be [ __ ] hurting myself
all the time and [ __ ] and i think
when i look at it now it is kind of
weird because most of the people who
stick with bmx are the people who are
talented
and i was never like the dude riding
wise like i i if you ask like real
people who know about bmx tricks they'll
be like adam admitted this trick this
trick he did he did a bunch of cool [ __ ]
back in the day but i was never thinking
i was gonna be pro and plus in hashbrown
town
there were no pros i didn't know anyone
who was sponsored like i knew like one
dude who lived like an hour away who got
free bikes from a company
i didn't really even understand that
there were people getting money for
riding and [ __ ] like that you know no i
totally get you when i was a kid i did
the i thought i was sick
before you turn it almost all the way
uh-huh yeah oh i was just watching x
games built you ever build the ramps up
that [ __ ] sucks dick building them in
the forest off that dirt there's people
who love that i know dudes have been in
the in the woods for 30 years they spent
their whole life digging jumps in the
woods that's their [ __ ] happy place
you know i've done it a few times
i gave it i gave that up when i found
like weed and [ __ ] yeah that's pretty
much what happened you know skating and
playing [ __ ] sports
in southern california you can't be a
bike rider or a skateboarder especially
not these days without realizing like oh
there's an industry around this and
there's people who are good at it and
maybe you could have a job working for
this company growing up or i grew up all
that [ __ ] was a mystery to me it was
[ __ ] a world away for you yeah i know
i do the east coast he grew up uh in
buffalo so he tells me the same shit's
like well i'm in the basement it's
snowing i'm just playing basketball in
my basement for four hours doing nothing
riding bikes bro i was i would
search for a parking garage that would
have like a curb in the parking garage
so we could ride it even though it's
like 25 degrees out and it's [ __ ]
you're freezing to death but like okay
the snow and the rain aren't going to
hit you and you're going to be able to
practice doing some 180s and manuals and
[ __ ] on this curb
yeah i mean that's growing up bro that's
the essence of that [ __ ] getting hurt
and realizing that i'll stick with it or
giving up and doing something else
i was never with that [ __ ] i never did
anything that was involved falling and
[ __ ] skinning your [ __ ] body up
and [ __ ] skateboarding
but i always had the other side of my
personality too where i was always on
the internet
always oh really
always i would ride bikes all [ __ ]
day like i would a normal day for me
like summer after you know 11th grade or
whatever uh you know go out riding at
noon be out riding bikes till like at
least midnight and then damn yeah yeah
yeah like every day
all [ __ ] days ride all day every day
in the same town all day just chilling
with your homies i don't know what the
[ __ ] we were thinking there was not [ __ ]
to ride but we would just be we just
were happy as [ __ ] to be out on bikes
around the city like you know i had a
decent family life but i don't want to
be around my [ __ ] parents when i'm in
high school and [ __ ] i just wanted to
get away i always i always think that
that's why i got into dmx as opposed to
skateboarding because bmx was like
boom i'm on my bike i'm pedaling 10
miles
i don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
at home my parents are yelling at each
other whatever i'm i'm gone i'm out that
was what gave me like freedom for real
were you guys doing drugs or no no i was
straight-edged like my whole childhood
pretty much until i was like 21 22 i i
smoked weed like one time in high school
and i one time i like took a couple
shots or some [ __ ] but i
i was pretty much drug free cause in bmx
like in the magazines and [ __ ] that [ __ ]
was really uh
thought well of like
that really like to be drug free at that
time was like a big trend like i hate to
call it a trend because it's a good
thing if you kids by all means
it's a great thing especially early in
your life i think being drug free is
beautiful thing but yeah so i didn't
really like think about drinking or
anything until i got a little older i
just got to point something out you
started scamming credit cards before you
started smoking weed heavy that is a
[ __ ] bold choice
yeah that's that's what i was like the
dabble the dabble i smoked weed you know
when i shoplifted or i was doing drugs
and i had to get money that's what i was
saying
you know the crazy thing about it was
that like when i think about it the
reason why i was cracking cards at that
time was because i met this one
czechoslovakian kid who put me on to
what it is to go into a store with a
fake credit card do a purchase how you
buy the credit card account how you get
the blank credit card that you're gonna
put that that account on to et cetera
just because i met that one dude who
told me like you know
you can make five grand tomorrow if you
come to the mall with me and do these
purchases with me i was like bet let's
do it and like
i was interviewing this one dude this
dude 23 in one he's like a a prison
youtuber and [ __ ] and he he was talking
about like his life stories like yeah
you know i was a pretty normal kid this
this and that and then i turned 16
somebody gave me a gun and told me about
strong armed robbery and that jesus he
just you know that just turned him out
and all of a sudden he's like [ __ ] i'm
getting money by putting a gun in
people's faces and [ __ ] you know
you could just be a little boy until you
get the wrong influence around you who's
just like this is how it goes in the
real world same that's what happened to
me man i was [ __ ] the tampa bay
raiders super bowl the night before that
i smoked weed for the first time and
everything [ __ ] i was a 4.0 student
until that day
wow and it all changed i started selling
weed to packs and boxes and then here we
are here we are
it turned out pretty good for you
compared to a lot of people you know oh
yeah man a lot of my homies well old
friends live outside we just got dr drew
in here he was [ __ ] astounded once he
started oh he's handing his backstory oh
wow yeah from you know it's merced it's
a lot of meth and [ __ ] like that um
but while we're on the topic on some
[ __ ] do you still
do the bmx clothing link for that just
bmx stuff yeah well it's like it's kind
of just like a brand that we've just
been doing my goal with it at least like
in the past my goal has changed over and
over throughout the years but my goal
with it now is just to have it be
a clothing brand that people folk with
that people look at in more of like you
know a hipster [ __ ] streetwear sense
that you know is rooted in bmx culture
because i feel like bmx has an amazing
culture and there's been so much dope
[ __ ] throughout the years
but you know it doesn't really get like
viewed that way or celebrated the way
like you know everybody loves supreme
and everybody understands even if
they're not really like tapped in that
supreme is a a really dope streetwear
skate brand and like you know that
they're celebrating the culture
surrounding it so with on some [ __ ] you
know i try to create moments that like
are just you know
exposing
the greater
world culture to like what bmx as a as a
culture is like and like we just did a
jam
under this bridge off rosecrans where we
just had all these crazy ass rails set
up we had [ __ ] matt come out and
announce this [ __ ] oh i saw this yeah
and it was like bro people were pulling
up all the [ __ ] gangsters from that
area pulling up people just chilling
smoking everybody riding crazy ass video
on our youtube channel from it and just
like that
a lot of like no jumpers audience and
[ __ ] they never
knew that bmx was this [ __ ] amazing
culture and we just you know that's my
goal is just put that out in front of
people's eyes like i just can't get away
from it like i've really kind of like
pulled back on bmx over the years at
times and i just always get pulled back
because i just love the [ __ ] culture
of it and it's something positive man
you just brought back brought how many
people together and nobody's sitting
here fighting and doing crazy [ __ ]
they're just riding and hanging out no
gangster [ __ ] no weird [ __ ] everybody's
showing love you got [ __ ] trans
people riding bikes you got [ __ ]
rollerbladers soap shoes skateboarders
everybody just having a good time gang
bangers
it's all good
damn yeah that's it sounds perfect man
never really considered that yeah you
know i saw the video um
it looks like some 90s it looks like uh
remember the ninja turtles when they
walk into the putty uh football it's
like you want cigarettes or you want
menthols it's like everybody's just
chilling out
that's what it looked like except all
adults and [ __ ]
a lot of people watching that video are
like commenting like bro i didn't even
know this [ __ ] still happened like this
i didn't know that
bmx still had this cool ass culture like
i thought the [ __ ] died with x games
whatever so it's like that's always been
bmx's problem like skateboarding
over it just overtakes everything
skateboarding had jackass they had tony
hawk video games they had tony hawk the
person they had [ __ ] a person you
know i'm just saying like there's ryan
sheckler they had [ __ ] rob deer deck
they had all this amazing shits jackass
all that [ __ ] bmx movies as part of the
culture yeah but like bmx is amazing in
its own right but like there was rad
back in the day which really that's like
the bmx movie uh from like the 80s and
[ __ ] but you know the culture just
hasn't really been put on on blast and
there's been a lot of bad luck
within bmx and to be honest i'm probably
like the most well-known person to have
come from like not i'm not comparing
myself to a dave mirra or whatever but
in this modern age you know it's like i
don't know any bmx rider as many
followers as me or whatever so it's like
i
kind of see it as like a personal
responsibility that i'm trying to get
more and more serious about is like how
do we really put bmx on display to the
biggest audience that we can
that stick randomly last episode i was
talking one of my best homies uh og he's
a dino collector he has so [ __ ] many
old school just that's a whole world
it's it's too much of storage
for these
so yeah the culture's he's like i'm just
waiting for it to come back
yeah that's what he always says i'm
waiting for it to come back and so i can
ride and [ __ ] see i never collected the
[ __ ] at all like all that [ __ ] is kind
of before my time like the 80s and the
90s bikes because i started oh yeah he's
on 97.
but yeah that [ __ ] that's the whole
world right there
well dude you're right there is no
culture we had [ __ ] tony hawk the
game and that overtook everything bart
simpson skate that's why i picked up a
skateboard because of [ __ ] bart
that's what
yeah there's no there's no bike
influence i can't think of anything i
mean you know matt hoffman and dave
meera like i think most people recognize
those names
uh matt hoffman kind of hasn't been
riding that crazy for however many years
he he's he's a cool spokesperson but i
mean tony hawk bro like tony hawkins
the dude like he still can go on
anybody's podcast and just preach the
[ __ ] gospel of skateboarding to this
day you know it's a beautiful thing so i
mean yeah i just really want to like
spread the [ __ ] as
as many people as possible as long you
know i come from bmx like a
massive hip-hop fan but i just like
don't like the idea of sort of letting
people forget about bmx i want to put
that [ __ ] in front of people's faces
that's good man it's a positive thing
too
well speaking of the hip-hop
you said you were a hip-hop head as a
kid that got you to make the
forum i read something saying you used
to be
involved in with a record company what
did you do with that um record executive
what did this say so okay when no jumper
really started popping off in like
2017 or whatever i signed a deal with a
subsidy of atlantic records called apg
and basically like it was we were
supposed to like do a label
and everything with a you know it was
going to be like we signed artists and
we [ __ ] put out singles and
everything like that
and it was yeah it was all right but you
know they ultimately just kind of it
only lasted like a year it didn't really
go anywhere it didn't really turn into
what we wanted to be when i look back at
it now i'm like holy [ __ ]
because the money that they gave me to
[ __ ] sign at that time i mean it was
it was the most money that i had ever
gotten at that time it's like 200 grand
or something and uh i was pretty hyped
but i mean yeah i wanna answer sign you
know goddamn record deal for 200 grand
now so i mean it's like
in retrospect it's like it was a cool
idea but
yeah i never had my heart in it
that's all you had to say bro if he's
like if you're not fully into it then
it's not meant to be and you can't put
your inner you can't you have to
delegate [ __ ] and you can't delegate
like
the project yeah building this company
has been like you know my life's work
sounds kind of weird but like you know
that's what i've been doing all these
years and just you know really
assembling a team and like doing
interviews is just part of that at this
point and like the team that we've built
just keeps getting bigger and bigger
it's kind of crazy like i just bought
this [ __ ] five million dollar office
building in the office it's for us to
just build out a [ __ ] whole compound
of just creating content
and we're getting a store i believe
hopefully fingers crossed that we're
getting approved right now to have a
store on fairfax and [ __ ] just really
just basically being able to put
the the culture of like you know hip-hop
and bmx and all these things i'm a part
of and just put it on display for the
world you know yeah it's bigger than a
podcast at this point man is that gonna
be like some fantasy factory type [ __ ] i
could see it going that route if it's
like
we haven't thought about doing ramps and
stuff it is big as [ __ ] but it's like uh
you know i think it's mostly gonna be
like podcast live stream music recording
slash office space basically just you
know be
just a really dope
spot for everybody who works there to be
able to sort of yeah we're we're all
like working right now like i mean when
i think about like when i was doing the
podcast in the back of the store on
melrose after the store downtown i mean
you're just like 10 people just like
working on [ __ ] every day standing
around in the back of this [ __ ] bike
shop like there's nowhere to sit and
[ __ ] the spot right now is a little
bigger but it still ain't that big you
know it's like [ __ ] it's still kind
of scrappy when you think about it so i
mean hey like it's just you know levels
keep moving up that's great though
that's where we're just me and him right
now so
that's the goal this year is building
out because we we're doing everything
you know what i mean it's so [ __ ]
much to edit and post and yeah clips and
youtube and everything
comes a point where you have to build it
out in order to have to growing things
yeah i mean like just the fact that i
don't even like i do a podcast i pick
the they send me time stamps i pick the
clips and the titles that's pretty much
it like i don't do anything else and the
fact that i'm i wouldn't be able to pump
out such a ridiculous number of
interviews if i was actually having to
be involved with the back end yeah it's
nice having a team who can do all the
chopping and the cutting for me yeah
that's awesome um how many episodes you
guys put out a week
so there's three
or four weekly podcasts well no so
there's the no jumper show is tuesday at
six live then
live
yes like live we do two hours on tuesday
at 6 00 p.m me a d and house phone and
then wednesday at 6 00 p.m is a d t rel
and dunno they do they do their show for
two hours and then thursday house phone
this dude blasi who's like a clothing
designer homie of ours and then uh he
also has our friend yuri they do two
hours on thursday night but then myself
throughout the week i also like this
week i'm doing like seven or eight
interviews with different artists so
i'll just be cranking them [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] yeah yeah you wouldn't be able to
[ __ ] export and do this and then you
can't you have to just be
you're the the fact that i still like
pick the titles and that's
understandable
that's like a lot of
you know i'm doing three interviews and
then i'm coming home and sitting in a
computer for an hour picking out the
stamps but i mean i used to come home
and
put the file and final cut air drop it
to the laptop [ __ ] uh
sync up the audio to the [ __ ] video
because back in the day it used to get
all out of sync all the time that's what
happened our first episode man yeah good
i'm [ __ ] happy to hear this man
you're putting [ __ ] work in i'm gonna
think about any of that [ __ ] thank god
oh man so when you say go live or you
guys just like live on youtube like real
good used to be on youtube yeah nice
yeah i love that there's something about
that that makes it a little bit i miss
when rogan used to go be live on youtube
but something about actually watching it
live that makes it a little bit like it
just hits different
yeah definitely it uh i love doing the
live stuff it's not really ideal for
youtube because oh and also i didn't
mention that
we also have the homie sharp
who's like a legend from vegas and he
has
a software yeah he has a consistent
podcast on the network as well no [ __ ]
but it's a little different because
he'll like record a couple episodes at
once he'll fly out and film six episodes
in the course of a couple days and then
we'll drop it over the course of the
month you know because he lives in vegas
so
no [ __ ] he has a show it's
well it's been said it's been said
i saw the the
soft white underbelly very it has to be
the same person yeah i met him through
that yeah oh no [ __ ] well the fans were
saying they wanted me to interview him
and then the software the dude mark from
software underbelly reached out to me
and he said this fool is down to be on
your podcast and i said okay let's do it
got like a million views
i just ended up tapping in with them and
saying bro this is what we're doing
we're building the avengers right now we
got a whole gang going right here bro we
want you to be a part of it he was
[ __ ] with it and he's doing
we just helped line them up with
different women to argue with and
he'd be talking to like all kinds of old
school comedians and [ __ ] he does a lot
of really dope [ __ ] and like when i look
at it like you know we're about to start
doing live shows
and like you know in front of audience
and stuff and it's like well we have
like seven eight people like and that's
just like
people who are on camera like every week
that's not even like there's a lot of
other people who are on camera like in
the vlogs or on the music stream like my
man kiki over there and [ __ ] and like
you know and and i seen it like when i
was at that jam i was just telling you
about uh
like you know people coming out of the
woodwork telling him that they [ __ ]
love him like not even talking to me
they watch him on the stream and you
know that's just making me realize like
holy [ __ ] like a lot of these dudes
really are getting their own fan bases
and building their own platforms and
like i don't know it's just like i'm
just very excited about all that
that's [ __ ] incredible man now it's
the avengers you have a variety show
that live tour is gonna be tight as [ __ ]
yeah well it's just gonna be one show to
start the idea of us doing a tour is
this whole i was saying that we were
talking about it and i'm also like well
how the [ __ ] are we going to make any of
the normal content we do for the online
audience if we were going around the
country touring
fake set you know on the bus you have to
put out the put out the what you're
doing live as episodes basically yeah i
don't know this is definitely an idea
yeah that's incredible man that's that's
awesome that's why you got the big ass
warehouse now i see yeah we got a lot of
moving parts
but also just to be able to have the
recording studio right there so a
[ __ ] could just pop in like
that's that's a big thing i want to do i
want to have a spotify
album that's like consistently coming
out where
we're just having artists come in like
when they do their interview they record
a [ __ ] couple songs or whatever if we
find if we [ __ ] with one of them we put
it on the spotify playlist so it's like
the theme of the playlist is just these
are all songs that were recorded in the
same place and no jumper streamed it or
vlogged it or had the content like on
our channel smart that's one thing i'm
excited to come up with that was just
that idea this is a brainstorm so that's
great we'll see how it works that's how
dj ski used to have his [ __ ] he'd have
the his radio station on the one level
and beneath it was just straight
recording studios sick
yeah marty comes from the hip-hop world
of the east coast and [ __ ] so
that's why he's always and i can hear
him yep let's go i can hear you when
you're saying certain names i can hear
you getting hyped in the mic
[ __ ] yeah so the way i was looking at it
is you're saying it's kind of my life's
work right so you're sitting there at 19
or 20 doing this bmx thing thinking i'm
such a hip-hop that i can do this the
way i look at it like you know as a fan
i used to i mean no jumper but watching
since i moved to l.a
i see it as like
the gateway
for artists to kind of launch a career
when they when you guys were first
started it's the first time i heard most
ninety percent of the people on there
and then within what a month or two they
have full-on careers it was like the
soundcloud hub of like no no if you're
going to be big you have to be on no
jumper first those are the glory days
because there were just like so few
options for podcasts you know like when
when okay when six nine was [ __ ]
riding my dick and asking me for an
interview every other day and [ __ ] it
was like
he needed me to interview him because
who the [ __ ] else was going to interview
him nowadays there's so many goddamn
people doing podcasts and [ __ ] that it's
like he wouldn't have needed to be
sweating me so hard even though no
jumper was like the place for that at
the time but like the fact that he
didn't really have a lot of options you
know it was easy for us to kind of like
be that and so like i very much still
try to like stay on top of
interviewing the up and coming artists
and everything like that i'm trying to
just like find more and more
on-camera talent so like you know that
that would be the real dream was to find
somebody who i saw as like really being
capable of interviewing the talent that
i would be
confident in them doing the interviews
that would be the ultimate craziness
because then i wouldn't even have to be
on camera doing it even though oh i
should love that that's your thing to
like get somebody good enough to where
you can just take the reins well now i
have you know t-rel and a.d they inter
they've been doing some interviews and
stuff and this i'm listening to [ __ ] i'm
like this [ __ ] is dope as [ __ ] like
they're that that's all of a sudden i
have other people who can interview
people on the channel for me that's like
you know kind of yeah that's kind of the
point you can do what you want then at
that point yeah
damn you just delegated your job that's
[ __ ] awesome
well it just makes it so we can make
more content no
you can't you can't be everywhere at
once man and the fact that you don't
honestly for the uh you exporting doing
all your [ __ ] that was i'm i'm so happy
to hear that man it took years to get it
all we go through so much [ __ ] he was
[ __ ] freaking out over a [ __ ]
export
[ __ ] loser
my program lost my whole [ __ ] morning
of editing
i was [ __ ] heated about an hour
before you guys got here
hey what's up guys just taking a moment
here to talk about one of our sponsors
this is fanduel this is super bowl
season guys it's coming it's close pro
bowl just passed this is the time for
everyone out there that's already into
online gambling and if you're not do me
a favor right now go to the app store
download fanduel sportsbook when you use
our code dope as usual you're
automatically qualified for this you bet
five dollars you can win 280. that's
pretty good odds yes five dollars can
win you 280 doesn't matter which team
you pick it's a 50 50 chance it's five
bucks and right now guys this little
disclaimer popped up right here you have
to be in a legal state this is an actual
gambling site so all the states are
listed make sure you're in a legal state
and you have to be at least 21. this is
a real gambling site if you already have
this app and you have your friend
download it and they place a five dollar
bet it doesn't matter
you get 50 bucks just for having them
referred and your friend gets 50 bucks
just for placing a bet for super bowl 56
guys there is no better place no better
odds than fanduel sportsbook so the
biggest question we got to ask today
guys who are you going for in the super
bowl i know i'm in la i should be voting
for the rams i get that i also would
love to see the bengals win it's they've
never won since i've been alive so
fanduel sportsbook app download that use
code dope as usual who do you think is
going to win who are you putting your
money on
what's up guys taking another moment
here to talk about one of our long time
sponsors this is on it before we start
you already know
onit.comnit.com forward slash yola that
gets you 10 off of everything on the
site except for the weights every single
thing that can make you a physical
specimen inside and out on it offers and
starting with the most important part
your brain one of the biggest products
they offer is alpha brain is essentially
a daily vitamin that helps you with
cognitive thinking focus
just being clear-headed that's been out
for a long time but introducing alpha
brain shots they have it in just little
shots easy to do right when you wake up
chug them tropical peach they're coming
out with more flavors also and not just
for being puff they have other things
shroom tech new mood for actual mood
enhancement they have the gut health
they have viratech and virotec that is
basically an immune booster guys it's
not all about just being rocked out and
looking cool it's about being actually
healthy how do you feel on the inside as
well as out if any of this interests you
at all guys right now go to
www.onit.comit.com forward slash yola as
i said before 10 off of every single
thing i just talked about except for the
weights
quick question
if you can interview your top two people
who would they be if if if
no music no regulation nothing no
restrictions anybody in the world that
you want to sit down have a conversation
with who would they be top two
well
i would really really like
to interview babyface ray right now and
put that out there into the world
because
from detroit he's he's one of the top
dudes from detroit right now
he hasn't really done an interview
uh
and he's smart on his part to maintain
his mystique
but he's definitely an artist that i
would love to get on the podcast right
now i was really dying to interview k
flock but then he got picked up for a
murder so i don't know about [ __ ]
yeah and uh i don't know man because
it's like you know i would like to
interview a drake or a you know insert
mega celebrity here that shit's always
fun but at the same time that's not
really like my thing my thing is like i
want to interview the kid from [ __ ]
baton rouge or florida or chicago or
whatever who's just starting to catch
steam and the whole world is dying to
know
about
who this dude is you know because i'm
like that's just how i've made like the
biggest impact with my content
throughout the years i was just showing
kiki on my [ __ ] uh
youtube analytics that the the xxx
centasy on interview rest in peace
still
in the last last month it's averaged 10
000 views a day i put that [ __ ] out in
4016.
damn so it's like you know i'm making
like
x amount of dollars still off that
interview but it's not even about that
but it got like three million views or
some [ __ ] in the last year
it's been out for that one like that is
that your biggest one i think that's the
biggest one like i don't even know if
there's a rap interview that has gotten
more views than that because it's at
like 12 million or some [ __ ] like there
might be but
i think it might be like the biggest rap
interview ever
at least close
so
[ __ ] yeah it's pretty crazy
that's awesome man so you
said um basically
blank ex-celebrity i mean a big
celebrity
that's cool i was just thinking maybe
there was some kid from your child or
somebody from youtube you know what i
mean like i was thinking the other day
it'll be fun to interview jerry springer
yeah it'd be so amazing it would be cool
but okay this is the thing when i
interview a [ __ ] young up-and-coming
rapper and he does his first interview
and he's like he or her it's oh [ __ ]
whoa the [ __ ] mic just popped off
god damn
freeway rick ross
free away from us that's the only time
something's ever happened i was talking
to this guy he said something funny as
[ __ ] i laughed
somehow smacked myself in the face my
headphones flew off my head wow
mid-sentence
that [ __ ] was tight all right i'm just
gonna leave this [ __ ] alone
all right
sorry all right we're good
we're back
my bad
i don't remember what the scent what
sentence you left off on now my bad it
was something about just how
when you're interviewing a young guy for
the first time a young artist for the
first time you know really getting that
first
conversation out of them or like laying
that blueprint for their career i don't
know there's something about that that i
kind of consider like the integral
part of
no jumper which is kind of different
because like you know interviewing jerry
springer would be sick but it's like
is there any question that jerry
springer hasn't been asked you know like
you're really totally just covering
ground that's already been covered for
the most part now i would if if i was
going to interview jerry springer like
any time like it's someone who's done a
shitload of media over the years like
another person i thought about naming is
it would be cool to interview joe rogan
uh just because that was kind of like
the person who like influenced me the
most on in terms of my style or what i
thought a podcast was in the early days
you know
um but i mean if i would just feel such
pressure in interviewing joe rogan that
i would have to like really like scrape
the catacombs in my brain to think about
what i want to ask him because he's he's
so i mean he just has had more
podcast experience than almost anybody
so you know sometimes i do podcasts with
people who like claim to be like you
know the biggest [ __ ] fan in the
world and then it's like they're kind of
asking me like super basic ask questions
you know and it's like
you know it's just like that like a lot
of people do that i take a lot of pr i
overthink the [ __ ] so much that it's
like if i when it comes to interviewing
somebody who i really like know and
respect et cetera
it's like pressure's on i end up kind of
like overthinking it sometimes yeah
totally understand that man and
sometimes that's not what the fans
really want from you too we've noticed
that like we'll be super [ __ ] excited
and then it won't really hit like we
thought it would but then you know like
our our biggest episodes are youtubers
compared to like you know the select big
celebrities a lot of times those are
people who don't really have other good
interviews you know like
i totally see what the [ __ ] you're sure
a lot of youtubers are kind of like
under interviewed you know like you have
you a lot of my biggest interviews are
youtubers for sure yeah
no [ __ ] just because i think a lot of
the fans really want to know those
people and a lot of times
they you know like there are a lot of
opportunities now i mean like there's
been many times where it's come time for
me to interview a youtuber and i
realized that they already had like a
logan paul interview with like three
million views from a couple years
earlier you know just because
there are a lot of people doing the [ __ ]
these days you know
no i get it i like that perspective i
see what you're saying what hasn't jerry
springer been asked yeah totally
understand but i think it's a little
like
12 year old of me going
sick that was tight but i get what
you're saying getting the first reaction
because
that's their introduction to the world
besides this their music
so that's interesting that he's like
that's what i really look that's like
the vetting that's what i'm looking for
like we we're constantly looking for
guests that not only do we want to
interview that but the fans are going to
be into yeah so it's like they got a
pass through you're looking for a real
specific type of interview that's got to
be fun
that's kind of like ideal but it's like
you know
i interview all kinds of different
people in general just because i like
just like like one like combat jack was
one of the dudes that kind of like
helped usher me into the game early on
and i remember him telling me like
don't do so many interviews like just
space it out like do do one a week and i
remember just thinking like no i can't
do it like i got so much respect for you
but i cannot do it like there's no way
that i'm going to be able to tame my
brain enough to only do one [ __ ]
interview per week especially when like
someone like i've done so many
interviews i just like i remember i
interviewed a pokemon go youtuber oh
[ __ ] and got you know two three hundred
thousand views and it was like you know
probably 95 of my audience didn't watch
it but like you know other people went
and watched it and like
i just i thought it was tight as [ __ ] i
interviewed a minecraft youtuber
who had like you know 10 million
subscribers oh [ __ ] yeah do you use most
interviews you film or do you like pick
and choose after we use everything yeah
everything damn almost never do we not
use one yeah
that was something we filmed mm-hmm
that's a lot of yeah you guys are
pumping out a lot of [ __ ] and that's so
hard today monday through friday
plus all the other [ __ ] on the channel
you guys are [ __ ] killing it that's
so much content man that's fun that's
awesome it's fun no that's a job man
that's jobs on jobs yeah yeah and plus
um
there's another question
you're recently a new dad relatively
brand new
how has that changed the work the
workload
it just makes me want to like use my
time more intelligently like you know
for years at the shop on melrose i would
be like you know i would get in there at
noon
hanging out kicking with the guys
talking smoking
doing interviews boom ba bow like just
going back and forth doing content
vlogging [ __ ] putting [ __ ] on my story
i'll probably like leave and go home at
like midnight you know and like go to
sleep maybe like one or two in the
morning and like
barely see my girl but i was just like
grinding like i just i had like
financial goals in my head that i was
just really trying to
get to and so i would just be in there
going on live for six seven eight hours
i'll ever all just at night all the
[ __ ] time you know and like just just
grinding and like now i got a kid and
it's like a lot of times like saturday
and sunday i'll just be like
yeah you know i'm not doing [ __ ] i'm
just gonna kick it with you and the baby
and we'll just hang out and so it's like
you know i realized like part way
through after like she was a couple
months old i started to realize like
no you really gotta like
slow the [ __ ] down because this kid is
like gonna be a [ __ ] grown-up before
you know it and you're gonna miss it if
you don't slow down and it's like yes
get into the money is important
and you know you're you're doing her a
favor in many ways with that because
obviously a lot of that's going to
benefit her but you know it's just i'm
not doing i'm not like doing myself
justice if i just you know
kick it like at the office all [ __ ]
night and never like take time off to
just be around the kid you know and be
really present when you are around her
and like not thinking of having your
mind it took me i got three kids took me
[ __ ] forever to get that [ __ ] down
yeah still working on it
it's a fact it's good not working
weekends but you have to it's the only
way to go yeah because i can finally
like
like it's a weird thing it's like
if i never like really got to the money
to the point that i have then i probably
would have like spent my whole life just
hustling trying to get there you know
thinking like oh if i have this much
money in the bank then i'll be good you
know but it's like because i actually
like have gotten there it's like the
same thing with like you know i [ __ ]
like [ __ ] 500 girls or some [ __ ]
she's just like
so it's like you know but i remember
being young and being horny as [ __ ] and
just thinking that it would be the
sickest thing in the world to have
threesomes and foursomes and all this
crazy [ __ ] and like
now i did it and i [ __ ] like every
porn star in the world and [ __ ] and it's
just i'm glad that i did it because i
know that it don't really matter that
much you know
that's the only reason to do anything
just so that you then it won't seem like
that big a deal you know
i think 14 year old you would high five
the shed for a nonstop like i mean
there's only so many porn stars you
could bang yeah that's [ __ ] awesome
man
i love that you brought that up that was
hilarious
milestones yeah yeah the milestones and
now you realize like no the time is is
more important than anything yeah
because you can't buy that
yeah you can't do anything with that you
can't the most i mean you you can be a
dad and you could go
have some [ __ ] orgy fun at night and
that's just fine but
definitely you got to make dad time for
sure
it's good to hear man
inspirational in a weird kind of way i i
know what you say like not for my kid
man yeah
i'll do orgies at night that was [ __ ]
amazing that's that's that's the episode
that's the name of the episode
humble
humble motivational orgies
uh marty what are we at
52. uh
how many uh do you do interviews often
i've only seen one other interview i
think i've seen with you oh like people
interviewing me yeah here and there you
know people ask usually well i mean if
they have like a good sized platform i'm
usually down i hate it when people ask
me and they got like 10 plays i'm like
you know i would appreciate if you would
like you know get your feet wet with
some other people first maybe
no i totally understand that yeah but um
yeah like i said we wanted to uh
have you here such a fan fans ask for it
every [ __ ] day yeah dude we'll
[ __ ] get there eventually like you
said we didn't want to go hitting up
people like by the way i have a huge
platform over here just started
interviewing people come on my show
right like we wanted to
you know get i want to be i'm a
perfectionist and i'm still trying to
think of
hey [ __ ] you already asked that
you high-ass you know what i mean when
we're looking at edits it's like there's
something there
that you have to perfect before you go
on stage type of thing how do you really
like get eyeballs on your [ __ ] from your
perspective like what's been the thing
that's allowed you to grow and get a fan
base
well i've been doing the
weed [ __ ] for
it's going to be a decade this year
right so i've been doing that like i
told you i've been deleted so many times
i'd probably be out like three or four
million you gotta really qualify it
better than that though if he hasn't
really if you haven't watched the dope
as hell and [ __ ] it's not just like weed
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is cinematically done oh
yeah we do wild wild [ __ ] this full
edits my stuff our
i don't say it often it's the best we
should on the on the planet i want to
see somebody else like do it so i can be
like [ __ ] yeah he did some dope [ __ ] let
me go do some more dope there's nothing
else there then i got to see more of it
you got to see a couple videos and it's
the story times though the story time is
story times is what made my channel so
big so basically i used to sell hella
i used to sell a lot of packs when i was
a kid um i have a super photographer man
i remember everything about my [ __ ]
life so i'll be sitting there telling
stories and it's got like 60 70 million
views of my story just me type talking
smoking a joint holy [ __ ] and that's
that's how my youtube got big
and then i said [ __ ] it dude people were
sitting here in my lives for thousands
of people for two hours let's do a
podcast right and mari's been working
with you know rogan and [ __ ] adam
kroll and theo for
a decade
so he came at me like yo if you ever
want to do podcasts let me know and then
we
worked on some [ __ ] first
got it started last year
and that's how we got the fan base
that's why our fan base everyone's so
[ __ ] cool everyone's
the same
like-minded person you know what i'm
saying right everybody's just a positive
person wanting to smoke oh okay cool
we're hanging out watching and now it's
like
a lot of people don't have people to
hang out with they watch your show like
[ __ ] yeah i'm sit smoke bowls by myself
i'm gonna do my homework watch the
[ __ ] no joke podcast it's like broken
was for our generation like you were
saying we were trying to do that for
that 18 to 24 now yeah you know show
tell people our mistakes how financial
[ __ ] that we [ __ ] up on i used to sell
packs you should probably stop my
friends are in prison right now doing
certain things don't do this while
shipping pack that's probably why we're
so demonetized growing up with wild ass
parents and children yeah like my mom's
marriage will [ __ ]
i lean for [ __ ] white supremacists to
go to the [ __ ] prisons every weekend
to visit his ass and your mom is married
to a white supremacist that's who she
was oh she was she was in prison at the
time wow she's got low standards no she
met him out oh my mom's also a [ __ ]
jerk and she didn't give a [ __ ] and my
mom's jewish and he was a straight it
was a big ordeal but i grew up with that
i don't speak spanish in the mexican
town don't speak strange i don't speak
spanish my whole family does because my
mom raised me
and
there's a big stigma around that huh oh
yeah i get like the spit the spit looks
when i go to mexico really because you
can't they're like what's that and
speaking of spanish i'm like oh no sorry
bro you can't like pick up on it a
little bit because like i i've no i know
when people talk [ __ ] i know when
they're asking someone if i know
somewhere and trying to get somewhere i
can't have a conversation with my
grandma's [ __ ] sister it's just crazy
because like i spent like you know i
spent a month straight in barcelona and
i've been oh wow spent plenty of time in
uh mexico and [ __ ] i did a couple years
of spanish when i was like 13 in school
i don't know [ __ ] like terrible like
nothing
hello mexican friends speaking spanish
well i don't know they don't really
speak spanish around me i guess but like
i don't know it just feels like in
southern california i'm around spanish
all the [ __ ] time my [ __ ] house
keeper is spanish you don't really speak
the best english but i still just
can't pick up on it if someone sat me
down and we just learned every day i
think i go back to school like in my
house yeah i could pick up how about
every kid i ever went to school with
[ __ ] took seven years of spanish and
can't speak a [ __ ] word yeah
two three years old [ __ ] i don't
remember none yeah i don't know [ __ ] i
learned i'm sorry but whenever like when
i say it in barcelona for that month i
started to like pick up on [ __ ] and all
of a sudden i'm thinking like you know
what i'm gonna download the [ __ ]
rosetta stone and i'm gonna [ __ ] do
this [ __ ] i'm gonna actually learn this
[ __ ] as soon as i get home nope back in
my american bubble no i don't care about
anybody i ain't learning nothing damn
that's how i am [ __ ] yeah i'm ready out
of school why do i gotta sit here and
learn [ __ ] i learned programming just so
i can edit that's enough for me for now
yeah i don't know i'll get to it but uh
before we get here let me ask you one
more thing it's something we do called
who were you in the 90s
so basically you got to put yourself in
your perspective of you in the 90s not
right now the things you've learned like
i would have made a mistake
who were you in the 90s i'll ask you two
things just pick from that okay all
right
vh1 or mtv mtv all [ __ ] day
that's the easy ones i was a kid you
know vh1 was adult contemporary yeah it
was boring [ __ ] in interviews about
drugs and [ __ ] michael bolton kenny g
it was boring [ __ ] like that that i knew
i didn't think was that tight yeah i
think one one one person has picked vh1
and every one episode it was [ __ ]
brian because he was oh yeah it was
brian keller
he did the vh1 [ __ ] all right
adam sandler jim carrey
adam sandler because [ __ ] i'm from
nashville new hampshire aka hashbrown
town i'm trying to make that stick and
uh
adam sandler is from manchester new
hampshire which is literally like a 20
20-minute 15-minute drive up on the
highway it's like the next city right
next to where i grew up so growing up
like a lot of the teachers in my school
and [ __ ] would have stories about like
oh i taught adam sandler because you
know he wasn't that old like when i'm in
high school and [ __ ] now he's a [ __ ]
old man but like yeah so he was always
kind of like the the local new hampshire
legend that like some people know
because there's so few like successful
people or famous people that come from
where i'm from so it's like anybody
who's from there really kind of stands
out triple h the wrestler good [ __ ] just
brought him up
too
wait you had him on no i just brought
him up last episode yeah he uh he he's
from where i'm from allegedly and then
mandy moore allegedly is from there but
i don't think like lived there for very
long
damn man that's [ __ ] hot i don't
sound like i'm probably never going back
realistically so i mean that's why you
still got your family out there no then
it moves out here oh then yeah there's
no point am i going back from yeah
there's no point
in trees and [ __ ] yeah i gotta ihop in
k-town yeah i got you
um
tupac or biggie
tupac
just had a better relationship with his
catalog earlier biggie i always say this
is like i don't want to sound like a
hater or whatever but biggie had like
an album and then he died and then they
put on another album and they're both
classic albums
but that's like a pretty small catalog
in comparison and i get why biggie's
such a big deal
tupac to me
you guys i saw up close and personal
because i watched his whole career like
every album pretty much and like you
know i just loved his catalog and his
growth and
seeing everything happen with him to me
he's like you know i've just read a lot
of like analysis of him as a poet and
stuff and i don't know to me he's the
artist with more depth even though i
love biggie
great explanation
yeah i feel everybody says biggie but i
feel the same way like he tupac had an
energy that was just unmatched that you
just was like more well rounded for sure
but i'm just i was listening to [ __ ]
ready to die this morning
in the shower
um
this is the easiest one for me
step-by-step for family matters
oh
yeah family matters yeah oh it's a
hesitation i never saw one right no [ __ ]
you [ __ ] step by step like that i
[ __ ] with it too though it was cool
yeah like i mean like
it's underrated the fact that like when
i was i don't know like seven or eight
or some [ __ ] that like urkel was the
funniest [ __ ] thing in the world the
biggest meme every kid loved it every
kid didn't i do that yeah you know and
first meme it was such a viral thing at
that time he was so beloved like i don't
know if you could really complain
[Music]
[Music]
kell that's the name of my pipe out
there his name step on her kale i met
him at a party
i'm like you know
my pipes named stefan arkell he laughed
i made my whole [ __ ] night although
like in retrospect maybe
you know like they have the the phrase
like jumping the shark you know when
when like you know a show kind of like
has just gone too far and they just
can't really come back from it
maybe like
the time change the time
time traveling chamber that urkel was
getting into or whatever that turned him
into stefano
yeah maybe that was like when the show
kind of like had officially just yeah
too far
the last season was a
[ __ ] show i didn't know they added on
urkel late and like while the show had
been going and then they sprinkled urkel
in and it worked and then they're like
hey guys he's the new center of the show
and the rest of the cast resented him
for that [ __ ] no [ __ ] you know what i
think it's cool is that the dad on that
show is gay and then also uh uncle phil
from
fresh prince
is gay carl winslow's [ __ ] gay what
what is it about like you know
the gay people that are they're better
at like expressing like everyday
heterosexual life on tv than actual
heterosexual people you're blowing my
mind they're just good actors like you
can't be a great actor i don't know
[ __ ] yeah i hope i'm not like
wrong
oh not easy pulp fiction and forest gum
damn [ __ ] i love both i've seen stars
so many times
me too
i really [ __ ] with pulp fiction though
so i think i'll probably take that
although i think i honestly like
i went a long time in my life
i would say i like stopped crying around
like the age of like 12
and then like in the past couple years
i've managed some good cries like i've
kind of opened up again like to be able
to do that but like i remember kind of
like cracking the seal a little bit
watching forrest gump when i was maybe
like 25 or some [ __ ] like somehow it
just really kind of like
it just really hit and i was just like
oh [ __ ] man
such a good guy
he's fast i'm gonna break this [ __ ] up
it's hard
he's got a heart of gold
he's the ncaa champion his friend loves
shrimp yeah i love that movie man i
wouldn't like that movie any day all day
or truman she's a girlfriend
she does have a's no one else yeah yeah
no jenny's not this is a reoccurring
topic on the shows we don't believe it
we don't [ __ ] with jenny here no we
don't [ __ ] with jenny she brought a's to
him she puts a homie at risk
it's your son i hope she may [ __ ] uh
uh forrest throwing a jimmy man because
that's [ __ ] up that's not [ __ ] up
you [ __ ] a hot girl with aids if you
work on no no [ __ ] no damn man your face
oh
it's like almost impossible to get it
from a vagina anyway bro
hmm i bet you [ __ ] plenty of girls who
[ __ ] got
got hiv and
you just let it rock
oh [ __ ] that took a dark turn man
no but no i wouldn't if that was a
choice i'm i'm a pass i'll go like smoke
you do things that are like riskier than
that like every time you get in a car
it's probably riskier than that it's me
it's very rich through a condom like
you're only getting aids through blood
pretty much we don't know the science
behind the show i'm saying i think you
should you should dabble oh look you
should
yeah this took a great turn yeah yeah
this is what we're talking about in turn
this is definitely not a forest guard
okay
jesus christ the original it or chucky
tim curry it or chucky i don't even
think i've seen either of them honestly
whoa i don't really like i don't ever
get drawn to like horror movies are
scary but as a kid they didn't neither
of them really scared you i might have
seen chucky but i don't even think i've
seen it maybe i didn't tim carrey it's
good as [ __ ] yeah original ones we got
to put freddy krueger on in there yeah
you're right you're right
okay everybody's seen that all right
mario or donkey kong
mario good job cause i got like you know
nintendo right when it came out and 91
or two or whatever the [ __ ] that was
and it was just like
mar you know it comes with mario and
then duck hunt and duck hunt is okay
shows the power of the gun that's pretty
cool it's actually kind of amazing that
they were able to pull that off back in
the day yeah but then you know mario
like he was he was
dude like the game like the only game
that you gave a [ __ ] about was mario and
then like you know zelda comes and
that's cool and like then you start
having some variety and obviously now
there's five million [ __ ] games but
i remember finally the days where mario
was the only thing and
that was okay yeah he's a little [ __ ]
plumber he's cute he's [ __ ] cool he's
got a brother who wears green and he's
taller than him it's crazy
i love you capturing a princess no i
[ __ ] with donkey kong but like it's okay
that's all right i never really got that
into it but yo i'm stupid good at tetris
really i played tetris
i was so good at it on nintendo back in
the day and then nintendo switch they
came up with tetris 99 which is like a
[ __ ] battle royale format so it's
like fortnight where you have 100 people
or 99 people and you battle to get
number one
a year of my life i spent playing this
game non-stop like every day i'll get
home from [ __ ] work playing tetris 99
like damn from work playing tetris oh i
was playing so much and then i just
stopped cold turkey cold turkey are you
a gamer
i play online poker now gotcha i used to
be a gamer hardcore but then i just kind
of fell out of that rubik's cube nah i
never got into that i was i said i
always wanted to learn but i i get it
like i started watching videos about how
you do it
and i kind of get it
but i just
kind of lost interest before i actually
like follow through with learning like
the next like 50 steps you know like i
learned like step one and two of like i
started to feel like oh i could see how
this works
yeah that's where i'm at with motion
life
oh what the [ __ ] we do have it you're
high huh full how we're bulva full house
are saved by the bell
say about the bell was everything to me
i [ __ ] with family of full house it was
sick saved by the bell was like it's
over rules it's just so [ __ ] up
because i it's the same reason that i
feel like euphoria is [ __ ] up i just
got done watching euphoria and it's like
it's so good but it's like you know they
have like the hottest [ __ ] 28 year
old chick 25 year old chick whatever and
she's supposed to be playing a 17 year
old so it's kind of creepy because i
remember being a kid and like looking at
ac slater and zack morris i was just
talking about this on podcast and
thinking like
how the [ __ ] am i gonna compete with
these guys like these grown ass men
dripping and swag and [ __ ] like kelly
kapowski she's like [ __ ] a million
times hotter than any girl in my school
like you know it just creates like such
a [ __ ] weird expectation for kids
when you have these adults thought about
playing children you know that's a yeah
i just start right now i just saw mario
lopez like yo he's brown he looks like
my dad oh [ __ ] jerry girls like my dad
but you know he's a big [ __ ]
with muscles and [ __ ] she was like cool
like that when you're like 16. whatever
happened to zack morris mario he's on
the csi show now is he yeah oh that's
cool he's still doing some [ __ ] every
time i see him like [ __ ] zack moore
is this guy damn okay yeah i [ __ ]
love that fool also i would like to
nominate the office
for what i love it's just my favorite
show i've watched the office
more than any show in my like adult life
pretty much of all time that's my
favorite show i've been watching it with
rosie
i took a six month break
last year because i watch it every night
really as i fall asleep and smoke weed
for the past well going on 11 years i'll
just
pop in here and there and like watch a
season it's bad randomly you know you
know i do a thing like hey you pick your
favorite episode of the season and i'll
pick mine and then we'll just go to the
next season it's so [ __ ] awesome
because you don't know what they picked
you can't look i'm packing balls i'm
like yo what diwali oh [ __ ] it it's a
wally yo it's such a good like
would you pick [ __ ]
try it if that's your favorite show
please try it rosie and i do this [ __ ]
every day except for the past month i've
been trying to watch seinfeld only yeah
yeah seinfeld is like another another
i'm two
yeah i'm too stuck on uh
on the office and you [ __ ] know he
just got me the script signed script for
[ __ ] christmas wow for the office
yeah i [ __ ] got in my house a bunch
of random office shows random office
[ __ ]
michael jackson michael jordan
uh don't really give a [ __ ] about either
i'm too honest because i don't really
listen to like pop music or like you
know
anything besides rap pretty much and
then i don't care about basketball or
any sport really
so
probably
michael jordan just because i watched
that [ __ ] show about him and i
thought it was gangster as [ __ ] and he's
like a gambling addict and
i'm really like like michael jackson yes
i like i [ __ ] with a lot of his music
but i'm not like you know a huge fan
like spent a lot of my time really going
out of my way to listen to him you know
no but i'm saying like as a kid i
remember everyone at school
was on michael jordan so [ __ ] hard
every recess that's all everybody's
talking about of course so yeah that's
right that's why we put that in there
like
as a kid but if you don't care about
ethan then that's the perfect question
that we should
respect them both definitely but not and
they're not like really a connoisseur of
either their art forms so to me it's
kind of like whatever whatever yeah
all right so last one
i always do this
keenan the kel orange soda is what i
like to think of it or the light skinned
rabbit that's quick
as a kid in the 90s the light skinned
around a little light skinned rabbit on
the nest quick jar okay yeah if you had
to pick that or keenan and kale orange
soda what was it what was kenan kel
orange soda just this no just just
orange soda just the [ __ ] fact that
they would talk about in this [ __ ] no
i'm just saying he and the kill because
it makes him more 90s because it makes
it more
in my head oh okay i'm just saying
orange soda and joe because you can't
say something versus versus as a quick
as a kid man you know i never really
drank a lot of chocolate milk or
i don't know
damn these are the these i've never had
anybody go nah i'm never really crazy i
don't really [ __ ] with any of this [ __ ]
it's the first time it's ever happened
and like you know i would drink orange
soda for sure a little bit but like i
don't know honestly my parents were
pretty
smart because i wouldn't really want my
kid drinking like [ __ ] a bunch of
like you know sugary [ __ ] [ __ ] no but
in the 90s man we were eating i would i
was i'm [ __ ] fat i was eating gushers
and [ __ ]
so that's why i break this yeah
i was definitely in candy all the
[ __ ] time but my parents didn't give
me like a lot of like sugary drinks so i
never it was never really my thing this
honestly the fact that i'm drinking a dr
pepper from the burger stand around the
corner is pretty [ __ ] hilarious to me
right now
yeah
damn man yeah i got to switch these
questions up man
all right well that was it dude thank
you that was who were you in the 90s
fire [ __ ] yeah so these are both out
perfect [ __ ] timing
and marty you want you got anything else
you want to add i think it's interesting
you two both pulled your names dopaziola
no jumper out of lyrics
but i always thought no jumper was a
reference to the biggie lyric you're
slanging crack rocker you got a wicked
jump shot i just assumed that no no no
but i just looked it up and it's not
that oh no no gucci mane yeah what about
that stood out to you that was like
ended up being the name of your show
just like uh early on it was supposed to
be like a blog about like underground
rappers before it ended up being a
podcast with underground rappers you
know so like i remember
out of the brand names i've done that
was kind of the one that we put the most
thought into where we had like a whole
big list of like 100 different rap
lyrics different little like chunks of
songs and [ __ ] like at one point i
really wanted to call it up north trips
and then i realized that was like a rap
blog
as well as a song so i was like uh i
can't like swagger jack that
uh but then yeah we landed on no jumper
because gucci says
95 air max because i'm a dope runner
bawling like an athlete but got no
jumper
and
thought it was kind of clever like no
jumper you know like
you're getting money but you can't play
ball
so you found another way to get money
because like in the beginning i was
doing a lot of interviews with like you
know people that were like the third in
command you know like the there's like
the star rapper and then his his homie
and then his homie and i was doing
interviews with like you know whoever
the [ __ ] would let me interview him
because i was just really trying to get
in the game so it was kind of like you
know we were just really like you know
just because somebody's not the star
rapper
you could still yeah of course good
conversation okay you know [ __ ] yeah you
[ __ ] with griselda we're big on griselda
yeah i have benny on the podcast like
three times good [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's why i asked that
oh no [ __ ] yeah yeah we're trying to
we're trying to get him on here too yeah
that's just that's i mean buffalo that's
that's all him yeah benny's the man i
love seeing that [ __ ] happen i'm sure
you can appreciate it because they're
really independent i'm sure you know
their whole background and [ __ ] but even
when back in 0.405 i always tell him
like benny was putting out mixtapes and
[ __ ] back then that ten to talk series
part four he's about to drop [ __ ]
started way back then that's crazy
montana i was oblivious
i didn't know what the [ __ ] they were
doing up there i was [ __ ] listening
to papoose and [ __ ] yeah let's go yeah
did you was it were you ever like damn
i'm into this like new york legendary
hip-hop i'm trying to tap into this
newer age of hip-hop did you is was it
like a gray area of i don't actually
listen to a lot of this [ __ ] no because
the thing was is that i was like uh you
know it was like 2014.
15 or whatever and like there was just
such a dope scene
in
downtown l.a you had like ham on
everything putting on crazy ass shows
with like you know riff raff and
crayshawn and [ __ ] you know uh like
you know soulja boy and uh like all
these artists who were like really
buzzing at the time and so i had always
like all through like i was never like a
rap fan like feeling the need to have an
opinion about every single [ __ ] thing
that was going on in the rap game it was
just like i had the rap that i liked
that i paid attention to and then there
was like a bunch of [ __ ] that i wasn't
interested in you know and then around
like 2011 2012 or whatever that's when
you really started to have like
underground
rap online popping off where all of a
sudden you could have like an odd future
who just like exploded with no industry
co-signs just because it was like some
cool [ __ ] asap mob uh the whole white
girl mob [ __ ] whatever like action
bronson riff raff all that [ __ ] coming
out at the same time and like so i
started like really going to those kind
of shows and like warehouses and [ __ ]
and uh so that's just like what i was
[ __ ] with going to those shows doing
coke taking drugs [ __ ] drinking like
going crazy
and then all of a sudden like we have
this bike shop it's right in the middle
of downtown you know we have like little
peep is like living around the [ __ ]
corner with little tracy like staying up
all night every night recording music
and [ __ ] you have [ __ ] you know like
puya just stopping by like all these the
playboy cardi is riding a [ __ ] bmx
bike around downtown just stopping by in
the middle of the [ __ ] day like all
this [ __ ] was just happening in that
area or in that at that time and so it
was just like a supernatural uh
transition for me to just start doing
content with all kinds of people like
that that's super authentic yeah just it
just was where you were at and what you
were living yeah i was just hanging on
this [ __ ] bike shop trying to make
something happen every day doing doing
vlogs doing interviews just really like
i remember at that time my goal was to
get to 10 000 a month on youtube and it
just felt like i had just been grinding
for like years and years with like the
[ __ ] dollar amount just floating in
the same area
and like when no jumper started to pop
off actually was like
the month that the bmx channel also
started to pop off where i just had like
a random vlog at like 3 million views
and we got like a huge surge of
subscribers and like all of a sudden i
had like an 11k month on adsense and i'm
just [ __ ] like yes i [ __ ] killed
it i'm so hyped but at the same time the
interviews start going crazy and i'm
realizing like holy [ __ ] this is like a
way bigger opportunity and i'm way more
excited about interviewing rappers and
[ __ ] rather than like i was i was really
getting bored with it because i was just
kind of like going to the skate park
with the [ __ ] homies just making
iphone vlogs doing tricks every day it
was just kind of like uninspired after a
while so i just kind of burnt out on
that [ __ ] but right before i started
putting all my effort into no jumper
yeah
so that was two different completely
different channels
yeah the other channel still
you just search on some [ __ ] it's got
like 400 000 subs or something good [ __ ]
so how's the following mm-hmm
[ __ ] yeah yeah
well's never uploaded on but um
what are you gonna do
well dude thank you so much for being
here yeah i appreciate you guys thank
you for being here thank you for smoking
[ __ ] hitting the bomb yeah
kiki hit the bomb the giant ball
um appreciate you man thank you so much
uh when does the show come out again
what time tuesdays at 6 p.m
our california time if you want to watch
us live
come tune in get in the chat talk some
[ __ ] good [ __ ] you guys are in the
premiere
oh no we're just doing let me know you
guys are in the chat live chat and doing
all that uh no we don't well we we crack
the chat open at the end and uh and we
look at like the donations and [ __ ]
during it but uh we pretty much
keep the chat off so we can just focus
on the conversation for the the two
hours got you yeah [ __ ] yeah dude well
thank you so much for being here guys
thank you so much this has been the atom
22 episode i'm dope yola have a dope ass
day
i'm pretty high man
yeah it's only smoke like a [ __ ]
eighth and i'm pretty
the past couple weeks
appreciate you guys
[ __ ] yeah man thank you for coming
it's been turning a little every episode
then and it finally [ __ ] happened
[Music]
perfect perfect
[Music]